so you know you it happens every once in
a while but it was just it literally
weird you know but the food was amazing
the doughnuts our flight there was very
interesting
well away so we weren't sat together on
the airplane this is [ __ ] gonna drive
me crazy right here what happened
and I sat maybe he was i sat maybe five
seats behind him
and it just so happens that the guy next
to me was an attractive like bearded
writer from horse-like he wrote for vice
cuz I like peeked over at when he was
working on and he wrote you know he
wasn't attractive dude tall bearded and
the whole flight over Bobby kept looking
backwards at me
and he kept doing this thing [ __ ] I see
you flirt cheating on me I had to let
him know that she's taken yeah that
she's mine yeah it was on the plane when
we all like deplaned the guy was right
next to me and Bobby you obviously like
met you know met us up at the front of
the plane and he was just going off you
[ __ ] cheating on me don't do that if
you don't do that I turned around I just
kind of stuck to my guns he could he
might have still little number mmm you
may have done a number of things so guys
if you're listening you know obviously
I'm your life coach you know everything
that I say you know I'm right everyone
listening right now you know I'm right
you have to claim your [ __ ] I'll give
you an example if my iPad right was like
five seats back just laying on an empty
seat I'm gonna go that's my iPad let you
know I know it's there did Bobby Lee
just buy a seat he's rich oh my god if I
was rich I would do stuff like that
if I was rich I would buy like to coach
seeds would put a real doll in one and
like a little teddy bear in another and
I'd buckle them in and then someone goes
can this old lady sit right here sir
nope
oh because you're 75 and you should have
made money in your lifetime oh my
goodness
Andie's ageist oh okay no its
truthfulness tell him what you did to my
nurse this morning oh here's another one
my nurse though I bring it up but now
I'm gonna put him on the [ __ ] spot I
was in the hospital for an episode this
morning no big deal big deal but no big
deal we've talked about it before it's
okay just to let you know in the last
three years
kalila she has a heart condition and
sometimes we have ambulance at my house
we go to the hospital a lot the
emergency room okay also my dad being
sick I've been to hospital there I've
been in two more hospitals in the last
three years than I've ever have in my
whole lifetime it's crazy it's crazy
okay it's called life okay people
listening to me right now write
everything down they're not saying do
you know I'm sure I'm your [ __ ] life
coach and so I know how nurses behave
this [ __ ] every two minutes UK
right touching her
I think this monitors broken the guy
from the plane yeah no yes yeah yeah I'm
sitting right there looking at him doing
it he's cute too he was cute
yeah what race he's like half white half
Mexican I think no no he was welcome
they paint you a picture of exactly what
I look like this morning okay this is
another argument that we're gonna have I
it was I I mean I woke up mid sleep
because I couldn't agree so already I am
looking crusty as [ __ ] the blood is
drained from my face my lips are chapped
pale I am pale I'm just looking
disheveled god you're so stupid
sometimes I was I'm telling you right
now like you would have been like you
would have been like not there like put
some [ __ ] chapstick or something on
that's what you would have said all
right I want to see what this looking
very great are you done baby I'm done
okay good may I say this cuz we had this
argument the car driving back okay is if
Anne Hathaway who has a very pretty face
especially in her prime Anne Hathaway
yeah
if she wasn't made wearing makeup right
and she had just woken up and she and I
saw her in a hotel room getting coffee
in my head and I didn't know who she was
in my
and I wouldn't be look at this ugly
[ __ ] right here know you as guys we can
tell when a woman is just genetically
pretty even without them you know the
lights and the whistles okay I get that
I get that and I do believe there are a
lot of women who look very pretty I
don't find myself to be particularly
ugly I think okay yeah very pretty
[ __ ] I know but in this particular
moment
I just wasn't I was looking at a very
pale Stanley did you say it yourself I
look like Stanley Tucci he only looks
like Stanley Tucci when she's sleeping
and she has her head back and she looks
like you know Stanley cool from the car
or something
well can it be from the terminal the
terminal he's been a lot of things and
he's a very talented actor so young
Stanley Tucci yeah I'll take that
young Stanley do but anyway so this guy
I just want to let you know kalila I'm
watching he was like I'm gonna confront
him I'm gonna confront him right now
yeah and my heart was already not
feeling good again you have to throw it
out there claim it famous you don't go
inside your heart and go you know what
I'm gonna let this little outside know
so I Adam I didn't he'd say hi to me
everyone so I wouldn't even look up from
my I was playing video games I was just
kind of doing this you know me as if I
was above it yeah look I know what
you're up to friend right and this is
what I'm doing okay because that [ __ ] is
stamped he has to put leads all over my
body for the heart monitor so he has a
touch part of my titty no he puts it on
the [ __ ] nipple I'm sure it doesn't
supposed to go there
he caresses it with extra like sticky
ointment
okay he's trying to big [ __ ] yeah I
don't know what your name is friend but
Hollis oh it's Kaiser Kaiser there you
go Kaiser employs more than professional
Bobby creates things in his Alliance you
are you should go back to school and
figure out you know I mean all that
stuff
[Music]